all right they win you lose that's the
focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
now my daughter asked me about the whole
Silicon Valley Bank meltdown last night
and the best explanation I could come up
with was this
all right sweetheart the next time you
play Monopoly allow one of the players
to have unlimited money from a federal
government meaning every time they lose
money they get it back
and then see who wins the game every
time
of course the vide Administration was
scurrying to try to convince everyone
that it wasn't really bailing out the
bank at all no
it depends on what the meaning of the
word bailout is
let me be clear that during the
financial crisis
there were
investors and owners of systemic large
banks that were billed out and we're
certainly not looking and the reforms
that have been put in place means that
we're not going to do that again
well they don't want to call it what it
is for one reason and one reason only
now as absurd as it is Biden is once
again going to try to run as working
class Joe like he did in 2020 and so he
must get all of his media Pals to do
backflips to convince America that this
was a one-time thing
in order for you to believe that this is
a one-off and they have this under
control you have to believe that three
years of massive fiscal policy spending
that we've never seen before will have
only a limited impact on the financial
Plumbing of the economy and the markets
and that seems absurd Banks take risk
and all the banks took the type of risk
these guys were taking particularly with
short-term liabilities and long-term
assets mismatch you put that together
that is a that is a that's toxic
toxic indeed he's 100 correct now this
isn't 2008 at least not yet when the
housing bubble bursts completely
it's a bailout triggered by risky moves
by the bank the the depositors
precipitated by the Biden teams refusal
to deal with inflation back in early
2021. instead what they did is they
spent trillions of dollars printed money
drove up inflation and now this is going
to cost real people real money to fix
the administration says that's not going
to come out on the taxpayer do you
believe that
well I don't understand how it doesn't
come out of the taxpayers I can't figure
that one out so I'd like to explain it
to me I don't know
how do they pay how do they pay that
of course the taxpayers pay the bill or
somebody gonna grow on trees
but were it not for Biden the poor
depositors they would have lost
everything we see well again Biden's
team is partly responsible here and
those being bailed out aren't exactly
destitute grandmothers they're
sophisticated investors and they're
sophisticated players who made deposits
in this Bank in excess of what the FDIC
clearly ensures they all knew that they
were taking a risk in keeping that money
in that one bank but they did it anyway
now here's a partial list of the
businesses that you are bailing out
Roku had 487 million dollars in svb
our I Rhythm Tech had 54 million
Bill Holdings had 300 million
something called Ginkgo bioworks had 74
million Roblox
150 million
Lending Club 21 million and the list
goes on and on
well you can't make a moral hazard
argument here though say the globalist
that's not fair Larry Summers tweeted
today that this is no time for moral
hazard lectures or lesson administering
or for alarm about political
consequences
but my question is when is the time
right to ensure that there are
consequences for bad financial decisions
in our banks is any time the right time
the truth is when those taking undue
risks are mostly members of the liberal
Elite Class
it's never a good time to talk about
moral hazards
if you're a darling of Wall Street or
Silicon Valley being Reckless actually
pays off
talk about bad incentives for future bad
behavior
but how many of you think that the Biden
Administration would have rushed in to
rescue let's say a regional Farmers Bank
in Alabama where
eight tenths of all the deposits are
over two hundred fifty thousand dollars
well Andrew Ross Sorkin and a few others
described it this way in the New York
Times deal book today
if svb was just a small Regional Bank
that did not have ties to loud
politically connected Venture
capitalists and the Tech Community it
might have been allowed to die and its
customers individuals and small
businesses would have suffered instead
because it's Silicon Valley it commanded
attention
but again the experts brush all of this
off
this was an extraordinary situation it
was an emergency
they always scream emergency though
don't they when you're about to get your
pocket picked
and your constitutional rights trampled
upon from the pandemic to Ukraine to of
course the famous bailouts and tarp
programs in 2008.
the government looked the other way when
all the bogus financial instruments
pushed the housing bubble to burst
causing a massive pain for American
families
but as usual the banks like JP Morgan
and Goldman Sachs they got their big
checks from the government
every time the elites run the same
Playbook and when it's all over they
have more money in power and the rest of
America is worse off
everyone needs to understand that
self-inflicted emergencies Like This
Will Destroy faith and capitalism
reaganism promised a system in which you
took your chances and had to live with
the results
but that's not the system we have and
young people can't be tricked into
believing that it is
every time rich people get bailed out
it's going to further corrode what
little faith and is left in our system
and as for 2024 this demonstrates that
Republicans will need to focus on the
economy not woke schools or
transgenderism I'm not saying those
issues aren't important they are but
this is going to be an election like
1980 and once again it's the economy
stupid
Donald Trump instinctively understands
this
Ron DeSantis will need to understand
this as well and Surround himself with
populist conservatives who understand
markets and why we can't allow this
Twisted game of spending and borrowing
and bailing out to continue
now svb wasn't the case of the
government thinking it was too big to
fail the bank
svb was too Democrat to fail to connect
it to Biden he can't afford to lose
support in Silicon Valley and expect
he'll win in 2024 and he knows it
but remember this
the same folks who are applauding the
Biden bailout never blink twice when
working class people lose their jobs to
Outsourcing or to a workplace flooded
with illegal labor when pain is felt by
Blue Collar types the globalist response
is essentially evolve or die
so we need a financial system that's
transparent and clear to everyone
not one where certain rich people have
access to unlimited funds because
they're able to intimidate unelected
bureaucrats into letting them have their
way
it's farcical to say that every time a
single Bank fails we'll have a crisis
that will sink the whole system
that is a bluff that should be called
otherwise going forward
it will always be heads they win and
tales we lose and that's the angle hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else